aunque los ucranianos se las han
ingeniado hasta para llevarse a sus
mascotas no han tenido otra opción que
dejar atrás su hogar las cifras no paran
de aumentar tal y como reportó este
domingo filippo grandi alto comisionado
de la onu para los refugiados
entre las responsabilidades de quienes
causan la guerra en todo el mundo está
el sufrimiento infligido a los civiles
que se ven obligados a huir de sus
hogares la guerra en ucrania es tan
devastadora que 10 millones han huido ya
sea como desplazados dentro del país o
como refugiados en el extranjero es un
dato clave varios millones de personas
no tienen la forma de abandonar el país
y su desplazamiento es interno y al
menos 34 millones han logrado salir de
ucrania esto es médica en polonia es el
cruce más transitado por donde han
pasado más de la mitad de los refugiados
lo que podemos decir con certeza es que
después de tres semanas desde el inicio
de la guerra seguimos viendo flujos a
diario más de 10 mil cada día sólo en
este cruce fronterizo en médica
este domingo se han abierto siete
corredores verdes por estos pasos
humanitarios ucrania ha logrado evacuar
a un total de 190.000 personas un éxodo
que no termina con las tropas rusas
avanzando paralelamente a las
conversaciones para un posible acuerdo
de paz